We have a new type of loop in
JavaScript, and that is the for...
of loop. It's used to loop over
any type of data that isn't
iterable. We're going to learn
all about different types of
iterables, and we're going to
learn why this for...of loop is
so useful when we hit things
like generators and maps and
sets and so on. For now we want
to get an idea as to how this
loop actually works. What is
an iterable? An iterable is
anything that can be looped over.
If you have an array, you can
loop over an array, or a string,
or a map, or a set, or a
generator. We're going to look
at all kinds of different
examples as to when you can do
it, but let's get going with
looking at some of the existing
loops first, and see what are
the shortcomings of our existing
loops, and why does for...of
shine above all of them in a
couple of use cases. The
first one I want to talk about
is, I've got a survey right here,
which is just a regular array
with four items in it. We're
going to look at the regular for
loop. You've probably have
written this one over and over.
For let i = 0I < cuts.length; i++.
Then you console.log(cuts).
You've done that one many times
and you see chuck, brisket,
shank, and short rib. No problem
there. What is the downside
to something like this? The
downside is that it's kind of a
confusing syntax. In all of my
years of teaching JavaScript,
this is probably one that trips
people up the most. It does
make sense when you break it
down into the three parts, but
people look at it and get
anxious when you see it because
there's a whole bunch going on
here. Also, it doesn't read that
nice to me. You don't have a
variable called cut as a
singular of cut, you just have
cuts, and you have a problem
here where if you use a var you
don't have a closure, etc., etc.
It's good in some cases, but not
great because of the syntax that
we have here, so I'm going to
comment that one out. What
other kinds of loops do we have?
We have the .forEach array
method, if we say cuts.forEach.
That will give us a function.
Actually, we use an arrow
function there because we don't
need this. That is going to be .
forEach they're going to give us
a cut, console.log a cut.
That works pretty well. What's
the downside to that? Well, we
cannot abort this loop. We
cannot skip one of the ones. For
example, if I wanted to stop
once we hit the word brisket, I
would say if cut = brisket then
I would break, and then that
should console.log chuck brisket,
and then stop the actual loop.
It doesn't work because you
can't use a break inside of a .
forEach. Same goes for continue.
We can't continue. We can't skip
over that specific one, it's
going to yell us, illegal
continue statement. I like
the for each in a couple of use
cases, but if you need to be
able to skip over then that's
not a good one. So far we've got
these two loops and you have to
decide what you want. We also
have the for...in loop. We're
going to learn about for...of,
but we have for...in. For
const, let's say cut in cuts.
Console.log cut 01, 2, 3,
4. It actually gives us the
index, so you could say, maybe,
index cut. No, that doesn't work.
It doesn't let us do that. Maybe
take the const out? No, that
doesn't work. There's no way
for us to actually do that
either, so I'm going to bring
that back. This is actually the
index, and we'd have to console
logs cuts. That will give
us our value, just like we did
on this first one. That
might be OK, but one thing is if
you have ever worked with an
array, or someone has monkeyed
with the prototype, what does
that mean here? You may know
that there are many methods on
the prototype, like .forEach and .
filter and .map. However, some
people believe that you can just
add things to the prototype of
the array. For example, I'm
going to go here. I'm going to
say the array prototype, shuffle.
I'll turn off my ESLint here.
It's just yelling at me. ESLint
disable. We'll talk about ESLint
in future video. I've added
the shuffle method here, which
is kind of cool, because you can
do thing like this. You could
take your array here, which is
cuts. We could say cuts.shuffle.
Now we have this new shuffle
method that was just made,
because we added it to the
prototype of every single array,
and that will just shuffle the
actual array for us. That's
cool, but now what happens when
I console.log the index of
cuts? Chuck, brisket, shank,
short rib, function. What
happens? It iterates over
absolutely everything in the
array, including things that
have been added to the prototype.
It doesn't just iterate over the
items in the collection, because
what are the items of the
collection? The items of the
collections are chuck, brisket,
shank, and short rib. But it
also iterates over additional
things that have been added.
If someone comes along and says
cuts.shop = meats, watch this.
Now, all of a sudden, any time
you add a property, or a method,
or anything to the array, it's
also going to show up in this.
That's kind of a pain. You may
say, "That's fine but I never do
that," but lots of times there's
libraries that actually modify
the prototype. For example,
MooTools is known for modifying
the prototype here. If I am on a
website; I'm not even going to
use MooTools here, but I'm going
to make an array with var names,
and I want to iterate over them.
I would say for name in names,
console.log name. Watch what
happens. Holy smokes, we get
zero and one, that's the index.
That's going to be the name,
actually, but then you get all
this other crap. What's this?
This is just because the
prototype has been modified, and
that's what shows up when you
use a for...in loop. Those
three things aside, we now have
the for...of loop, which gives
us the best of all three worlds.
You're able to use the for...of
loop for absolutely any type of
data, except objects. We can't
use it with objects. We'll look
at that in a second. The way
that works is you is for cut of
cuts console.log. Actually, you
have to do a const variable here.
If you just do that, that's
going to leak into the global
names, so I'm going to say const
and cut. There we go. Even
though I've monkeyed with the
prototype and added this weird
property on to the array, we
still only get actual items of
it with the for...of loop.
You're able to use your break
and continue. If cut =
brisket, I want to break. I want
to stop the entire loop from
going. We only stop. We get
chuck, brisket, and then the
rest should not show because we
broke the loop. Here we go,
chuck and brisket. Similarly,
if we wanted to just skip a
whole bunch of stuff, if we
wanted to skip console.logging
brisket, we could just simply
say continue. That's not going
to break the entire loop, but
it's going to skip over this one
iteration, so we should see
chuck, shank, and short rib.
Why? Because when it was brisket,
we hit continue. It's like
having a return from a function.
It just ignores everything
underneath it, and goes on to
the next iteration of our item.
That's introduction to the for...
of loop. Let's dive in a little
bit deeper and see where else we
can use it.